j'accueille maintenant hélène roll et
jackie
bonsoir bonsoir
comment ça va ça va et toi bats toi
ouais super super ouais ouais
hélène ça va très bien faire une cei
quand ses vues oui alors j'ai un petit
truc justement pour tous les deux pour
les deux un bon comme sky news certains
s'étaient c'était lui ou entités où
s'étaient dit oui je suis moins lyrique
et vous oui ouais on fait semblant de ce
vous voyez on a été tout à l'heure que
je te vois alors ouais tu permets que je
te vois alors n roll bonsoir dont ils
sont dix ans 10 relais cela qui est sa
fin il ya un accent grave sur le dakar
on voulait d'abord des intrus n'y a pas
de bol là on y boles alors que tours en
course à la télé donc vous participez au
feuilleton les vacances de l'amour qui
est tourné fin novembre jusqu'à fin
décembre à saint martin ouais je vais y
participer sans y est encore fait oui à
l'ouragan lenny là oui j'allais toujours
d'accord et diffusion février 2000 je le
dis pour les amis d'hélène qui sont
nombreux un album en cours d'écriture
oui sortie printemps 2000 alors est ce
que c'est que cette nouvelle énergie
vous vient de votre nouveau fiancé parce
que j'ai un nouveau fiancé bars en amont
vincent
vous commencez à ces jeunes parce que
quand vous étiez enfant vous étiez prêté
par votre maman avec votre soeur sophie
comme demoiselle d'honneur à des
mariages sais pas c'est pas beau ça
prêter non enfin oui on allait on allait
à vous dire le contraire ça me dérange
pas j'ai l'habitude vraiment vous prêter
pour être demoiselle d'honneur dans des
mariages et sa famille c'était la
famille quand même c'était pas des gens
tu vois vous voyez vous y mettiez les
clauses et à la perfection
vous venez de ça j'étais fan de claude
françois un fan oui on a tous été
rejetés béchard d'amitié bien aussi
cette année charles oui vous faites plus
ah non c'est fini
pas de pot et alors vous avez eu un coup
de bol absolument incroyable et c'est
très stimulant
j'ai eu un coup de bol est absolument
incroyable en soixante dix huit votre
mémé qui paie plus la main mais paulette
paulette votre mémé elle lit le journal
paulette et elle voit qu'on cherche pour
un film ses moutons noirs de moscardo
avec dutronc une fille avec les yeux
bleus oui voilà
et comme vous aimez beaucoup elle vous a
quand même conseillé d'y aller vous
allez gagner 3000 candidate et vous avez
gagné le concours bien que n'ayant pas
les yeux bleus premier coup de chance
ouais gros coup de chance deuxième coup
de chance cp il y en a mille candidats a
décroché le deuxième coup de chance
votre maman organise au mans un concert
pour dorothée way entre autres à
l'organiser depuis un an des concerts
voilà du tout et vous parce que j'étais
avant c'est vrai tout musical dorothée
et moi même ah bon certains enfants
hélène voilà c'était en et agir aussi à
plonger
elle m'a serré dans le catering
cependant il vous rencontré jean-luc
allouche azoulay qui deviendra votre
mentor ou celui de 7
laissez vous avez fait dans la salle
vide tous les deux et je me souviens je
me souvenais moi c'est pas si vieux je
vais jouer quoi je vais pas jouer
chanter
vous avez chanté quoi des chansons
dorothée changer quoi vous connaissez la
chanson de dorothée jean colisée
quelques-unes bah oui mes nièces et mes
petits cousins et cousines
alors voilà deux coups de chance
absolument incroyable coup sur coup
le journal de paulette l'audition avec
jean luc azoulay et vous voilà lancés
dans mais c'est vrai c'est incroyable
moi je me suis toujours très intéressé
de savoir comment les gens quelle
qualité le déclic le la boîte à
angoulême pour fabrice luchini non mais
c'est vrai c'est d'ailleurs un moment
important dans l'émission c'est la
difficulté qu'on a mis à mettre en
branle
oui et c'était ce qui était à mon avis
le plus beau c'est cette difficulté et
ça c'est une chose à laquelle je reviens
de mettre cap a compris que cette
rencontre cette rencontre d'une maserati
oui vous savez au début de l'émission
chère madame monsieur thierry ardisson
c'est nous on est là depuis quand même
pas mal de est dans une espèce de lâcher
prise s'avère que lesly ja de l'abandon
des postures dégrade pas vous avez
remarqué ce côté est arrivée seconde est
arrivée dans la rétraction parce que ça
il faut savoir que j'arrive toujours
dans une inquiétude est que notre ami
laurent avait pointé juste titre ajusté
toujours au début je ne ramène pas les
choses à moi je fais tout nombre dans la
difficulté un peu de rédactions ce qui
est bien normal comme vous au début et
puis après il ya dilatation il ya
d'amour vous allez comprendre
l'attraction dilatation et c'est une
perspective mais là maintenant on est
dans une espèce de plus rien à vendre
d'ailleurs moi vraiment je n'ai jamais
rarement laissé place aux spectacles
sont prévus
ce que vous arrivez dans un climat de
profonde compassion presque de dérivés
on ne sait plus trop comment s'appelle
hérarchie son calme et plus personne ne
sait combien l'eau de gan
on sait plus qui est qui on sait qu'à
des sportifs de très haut niveau on les
devine on sent qu'ils ondes et le
physique et le génie de grands enjeux de
nu et on sait qu'ils sont mariés avec la
yougoslavie ne faut pas l'emmerder trop
c'est qu'alain chabat est là et que est
que nous sommes tous là qu'il ya eu
rencontre entre mai et août il ya eu un
truc vous arrivez dans ce climat vous
dis là émission normal je vous dis non
merci je vous dis émission je vous dis
un mot habituellement épouvantable
lâcher prise bon alors on continue à en
continu tous les deux bah oui oui on est
seul au monde encore 87 premiers 45
tours 89 premier album 91 premier baiser
enfin la série et 92 92
vous vous souvenez mais les gars sont
fous de ça moi vous savez maîtrise j'en
ai parlé très longtemps dans une
émission domaines de la société comme un
phénomène de société la ln magna ça ça
existe et 600 épisodes 6 millions de
fans dans le monde entier
cette série était vendu dans le monde
entier vous avez touché beaucoup là
dessus
ben ouais normal singe pas non mais ses
conséquences et non mais c'est bien je
sais pas moi j'ai pas de comparaison non
non bon vous avez fait un disque qui
s'appelle je m'appelle hélène pourquoi
vous l'avez quand j'en ai fait six des
bien sûr vous avez fait bercy faisait
faillite mais pourra vous l'avez demandé
que hélène je m'appelle hélène soit
retiré de la vente je comprends pas ça
moi j'ai demandé ça non je sais pas
quand j'ai cherché le dise qu'on m'a dit
il a demandé que ce soit retirée ah non
je suis désolé non vous n'êtes pas
demandé que le d'histoire tirer non pas
qu'on peut écouter beaucoup parce que
c'est tout simplement il n'y a pas de
second degré c'est simplement un plaisir
c'est toute une histoire parce que quand
tu as une jeune fille et c'est quand
même pour tous les gens qui ont eu la
chance d'avoir des enfants de 8 à 14 ans
peu importe
à cette époque là c'était quand même
pour le père une manière de montrer à sa
fille qu'on n'était pas trop cons et
qu'on pouvait vraiment se faire le miel
et les abeilles avant et hélène et les
garçons apprennent donc moi je me tapais
les deux et mine de rien vous êtes
redevable à plein père qui pouvait avoir
l'air de ringard et avec toutes les
problématiques qu'on avec ses enfants de
se rapprocher vachement bien d'écouter
des feuilletons de cette qualité là
alors dans mes blagues à paris un
sociologue qui s'appelle dominique
pasquet au service qu'il a fait il a
décortiqué des milliers de la sinne
femme est une femme
les cantiques et des milliers de lettres
et finalement il a trouvé que c'est très
positif et même là le feuilleton hélène
et les garçons c'est énorme
très positif il a dit que c'est un
programme de vie qu'ils aient réfléchir
et téléspectateurs les amis les parents
ça engendrait des discussions sur les
enjeux du couple les rapports hommes
femmes les limites de la liberté
sexuelle wee d'anjou l'allant rider 2 de
votre mec par exemple de l'huile était
hallucinant ce que j'adore raid ensuite
on y croit c'est les débuts de la
musique c'est d'aller recueillir et
précédé ce café canal plus après on les
voyait toujours prendre un tout petit
peu la guitare et comme ils savaient pas
hyper bien et les mêmes qu'on les
entende à faire
wellens vois pas pourquoi tout comme sa
musique s'asseoir un peu comme canal+
mouvoir les mec très humble a ses
défauts le il s'est fait simplement
débile guitare vous parler d'amour tout
ravi d'être ici on attendait sébastien
mallet directeur
oui quand même quand ils se réunissaient
s'appelait oui non mais oui
hélène avoué passer autrement n'hésitez
pas musicien oui
non mais je ne les critique pas je dis
qu'il y avait but ou défendre le dit que
après le miel et les abeilles qui nous
offrait une perspective large de laisser
ce que beaucoup plus là on était dans
des problèmes plus tendue avec votre
feuilleton parce que c'était un problème
du de l'incompréhension ce que vous
finalement vous étiez carré votre rôle
était une femme carrés qui mettait en
scène
l'impuissance quand même de ce garçon
qui était normal mais quand il y avait
le drogué nous rappeler qu'en y avait le
drogué le gars qui avait fait d'ailleurs
là votre mari le gave d'agde était
vachement il incarnait la raison qu'il a
fermé la marche demain tu vas rester
comme ça comme une loque
alors l'autre faisais mais laisse moi
mais laisse moi et c'est évidemment très
étonnant parce que c'était des gens qui
avait 75 ans un coup pareil qu'elle
allait mais on aurait dit qu'ils avaient
déjà des projets de gens d'une
cinquantaine d'années alors dès qu'il
avait un marginal
c'était comment il s'appelait est-ce que
c'était cricri que c'était bien dans
l'ensemble oui j'ai donc créé creeks et
myla rose
oui cerise et mûre la drogue mais ils
l'ont ils l'ont qu'ils ont croqué d'une
manière eux il ya drop délirante quoi la
drogue et qu'il aille votre mec
comment il s'appelait nicolas beau la
nique aux favoris un peu long de plus en
plus loin quand même
il avait les cheveux de plus en plus
longs et c'est ce que j'aimais beaucoup
évidemment c'est banal c'était ce salon
de thé enfin cette espèce de
[Applaudissements]
soit mais dès demain la caf et ouais
comme à dix corps et qui était le lieu
unique du marivaudage tient après le
miel et les abeilles
vous croyez que c'était facile de passer
à votre univers pas si évident et
pourquoi il y en avait une qui était
toujours flipper en amour c'était
laquelle qui disait toujours mais il n
comment tu fais toi ton compliments
jugement bien c'est quoi ce n'est pas la
lie la ville ali vous pouvez mourir à la
lys était effrayant parce que non mais
là lyon et c'est pas pour balancer sur
une actrice à la ligue qui peut devenir
fougue avec la nuit c'était la boudeuse
éternel c'était celle avec qui avait
jamais sexe et vous vous vous
apparaissiez éclaboussant d' équilibre
avec votre nico je vous haïssez à manger
des plats réussissons coupe celle là l'a
dit madame soleil a dit vous finirez
philosophes ou dans les ordres ses plans
b oui germaine way
même soleil s'était jamais je n'irai ni
philosophe et dans les ordres
j'en sais rien a dit à partir de 40 ans
ma vie allait changer ah bon
[Musique]